au maroc c'est le nom du dernier livre
de françois xavier goudemand cet ouvrage
parler des origines 201 nombre de
groupes rock et célia agathon vous êtes
avec nous ce soir pour en parler mon
frère vous avez justement parlé avec
l'auteur de au maroc oui alors a cédé
6,2 sur metallica ou encore téléphone
c'est long même si on n'est pas
forcément fan de rock on les a au moins
entendu une fois vous justin en tant que
grande fan de rock et est ce que vous
connaissez leurs origines
c'est vrai qu'on connaît pas toujours
l'origine des noms et bien
françois-xavier big man l'auteur est
l'habitant il ya un habitant de noisy le
roi a voulu les décrypter pour chaque
nom de groupe
une anecdote insolite lui est associée
comme par exemple pour le groupe muse
muse signifie normalement multi unit
spectre onic explorer même quelque chose
de très particulier qui est un
instrument astronomique qui pend
notamment les grands télescopes le lit
de front tu as essayé de se dire qu'il
fallait de toute les façons quelque
chose de mémorisable mais vraiment de
traits singuliers à raconter autour de
autour de ce nom et donc ce livre célia
cartonne sur amazon vie il varie entre
la première et la deuxième place des
ventes sur amazon dans la rubrique rock
hard rock et métal
je suis je suis ravi et ça prouve ça
prouve qu'aujourd'hui la musique la
musique rock en général intéresse
beaucoup beaucoup de gens et pas
uniquement les mouvements dans la vie
françois et xavier goudemand est brand
experts il s'intéresse à la construction
des noms de marques
il a d'ailleurs écrit l'an dernier un
branding heures rock star un livre qui
mêle le marketing des marques et les
rock stars
et c'est quoi alors un bon nom de marque
c'est dire il ya d'abord il faut savoir
que la langue anglaise est très souvent
utilisé est d'après l'auteur il ya cinq
points d'ancrage pour un bon groupe un
bon nom c'est comme une grande marque
faut qu'ils soient audibles lisible
identifiable mémorable mémorisable et au
mali au maroc social livre connectés oui
puisque sur chaque page
il y à un qr code est donc si vous ne
connaissez pas le groupe
vous accédez directement à sa page
officielle sur youtube et donc à la fin
du livre il ya aussi un 23 heures de
musique qu'il suffit de flasher codé
avec
est ce qu'il ya de nouveaux projets en
route et bien l'écrivain travaille sur
un prochain livre qui sortira
normalement cet été un roman
biographique sur une très grande star de
musique
merci c'est d'agathon goût d'avoir été
avec nos journalistes pour tv 78 on
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro
mais avec plaisir